Let's create a web application that
allows us to create multiple restaurant
menus without having to
change the source code.
We want to be able to create menu items,
read the items we've created,
update our menu items, and
delete items from time to time.
Hm, sounds like we
need to make some CRUD.
What's so special about CRUD, you ask?
Well, this four letter acronym
encapsulates all of the actions a user
does on a data-driven website.
Each time we make a new profile, post
a new status, write a new blog entry,
upload a new pic, or
add a new item to a menu,
we are creating new data to
be stored in our database.
Whenever we look through a friend's
latest tweets and pics, or
skim through our news feed,
we are reading data that was already
stored in an application's database.
When we correct the typo on
a blog post we already made,
modify the item quantity in our shopping
cart, or change our profile information,
we are performing an update on
existing information in the database.
And when it's time to erase that
embarrassing baby pic from our profile
or get rid of those items
in our shopping cart,
we're deleting information
in the database.
Virtually everything we do on the web
can be summarized with one little
acronym, CRUD.
I want you to take a look at
a few common website actions and
then decide what the CRUD is going on.